part three of chilling Adventures of
Sabrina is stuffed with Easter eggs
hidden references and monstrous secrets
buried in each episode yippie ki may be
lovers I'm Jan and in this video i'm
revealing 28 devilish details you might
have missed in shunning adventures
season 3 including the Riverdale Easter
eggs that reveal a very weirdly
connected universe they will of course
be spoilers so take care if you haven't
caught up part three opens with
Sabrina's terrifying nightmare of
wandering into hell and discovering Nick
encased in stone it's a clever bit of
foreshadowing for Sabrina's own fate
late in the season when she gets trapped
in the ninth circle of hell by Caliban
it's not until the seventh episode that
Robert reveals he's a Hobgoblin to Theo
but there was a clue to his true
identity all the way back in the fourth
episode when Carcosa called Robin by his
full name thank you for warning us Robin
Goodfellow the name Robin Goodfellow is
often used in English folklore for a
mischievous sprite or Hobgoblin and in
English mythology and literature such as
Shakespeare's A Midsummer Night's Dream
Robin Goodfellow also goes by the name
of puck chilling adventures begins to
introduce new monsters into its universe
when Blackwood calls upon an amphibian
like beast to rise out of the waters of
Loch Ness black would cause the creature
the deep one the same name as a species
of water dwelling monsters from HP
Lovecraft novella the shadow over
Innsmouth and another of Lovecraft
sci-fi horrors is reference when zelda
ways up the coven's options to avoid
getting killed by the pagans I could
flee perhaps to the mountains of madness
but the mountains of madness is a
novella by Lovecraft that features a
dangerous alien civilization in
Antarctica that lies beyond a mountain
range even higher than the Himalayas and
the word Carcosa the name of the
malevolent Carnival leader who arrives
in Greendale first appeared in several
nineteenth-century short stories as an
ancient mysterious City before being
used as a name of an alien city within
the Lovecraftian Cthulhu Mythos in that
universe Carcosa is home to hosta a
monstrous deity who's also known as the
unspeakable one something which ties
into how Blackwood describes the
eldritch terrors he plans to bring into
the world return to music and will bear
witness to the birth of the on speaker
karkos are in the pagans plan to
resurrect their old gods in an event
they call the great flowering for the
ceremony they place a sacrificial virgin
inside a giant green plant statue much
like the virgin sacrifice that a group
of pagans carry out inside a giant
Wycombe and statue in the 1973 horror
movie The Wicker Man and the pagans in
Greendale also were animal masks at the
coven's her moon celebration just like
the pagans do in the Wickerman at the
carnival the ferris wheel that Thea and
Robin ride is called the Berlanti wheel
an Easter Egg to prolific TV producer
Greg Berlanti whose shows include
chilling adventures Riverdale arrow
Supergirl and you this season also
includes several references to the
modern horror movie myths Ammar about a
pagan cult in chilling adventures when
Sabrina returns to find the pagans have
created an apocalypse on earth she's
startled by a couple of plant like human
zombies who appear to have a pair of
yellow flowers growing in their eyes
this is a creepy nod to one of the pagan
human sacrifices in the movie whose
victim also had yellow flowers in his
eyes in fact Sabrina showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa that specifically said
that films like that and the Wickerman
were always the kind of horror that he
wanted to get to play with and infuse
into part three and the flower crowns
the Greendale coven worth with a hair
Moon Festival which are an ancient
tradition used in many pagan ceremonies
also recently appeared in MIT's Imam
after arriving in Hell Sabrina asked
Caliban how they can get to pandemonium
and he answers follow the blood red road
where it flows and there you'll find the
throne of hell that advice is a bloody
reference to The Wizard of Oz and the
Good Witch of the North's instructions
to Dorothy
on how to reach the Emerald City all
your doom is following the yellow brick
room and like Dorothy in The Wizard of
Oz Sabrina and the gang also come across
their own tin man in the form of Tommy
Harvey's brother who died in the first
season of chilling adventures like the
classic movies tin man Tommy also has
problems with his heart but while the
original tin man believed he lacked a
heart
Tommy's heart is on the outside of his
tin costume another classic tale is
referenced in hell's forest of torment
when Sabrina and Rose go to pick the
Fleur du mal that Dorian Gray has asked
them to collect Sabrina warns her friend
that if they prick them
on the flowers thorns I'll go to sleep
and never wake up that was also the fate
of the princess in Sleeping Beauty when
she pricked her finger on a cursed
spinning wheel it's like something out
of a fairy tale and remember that
Princess Aurora was also known by the
prickly flowery name of Briar Rose also
in chilling adventures the flower even
sings and calls to Sabrina and Rose
luring them into a potential trap
similar to how Maleficent entranced and
tricked Aurora into pricking herself and
later after they bring Nick back from
Hell to the mortal world
Sabrina wakes him with a kiss akin to
how Sleeping Beauty was woken from her
curse the evil flower that Dorian Gray
asked Sabrina to get for him is also a
reference with set of poems by Sharla
collie Fleur du mal appropriately for
chilling adventures Baudelaires
collection of poems includes one called
the litanies of Satan which fiercely
criticized the 19th century Church and
also inverted several prayers from the
Catholic Mass and substituted Mary's
name with Satan's likewise churning
adventures also likes to flip common
religious expressions in other words
fact the heaven are and in part three
Zelda's prayer Hail Lilith is an
inversion of the traditional Catholic
prayer Hail Mary full of disgrace curse
said o you amongst women and curse it as
the fruit of demons
Sabrina manages to reverse the pagan
apocalypse but in the process she also
decides to allow a double of herself to
exist at the same time
this twin Sabrina's situation is
something that already occurred in the
90s sitcom Sabrina the Teenage Witch at
the end of the third season of the old
school show Sabrina met her identical
twin Katrina and they had to undergo a
test to find out which sibling was the
evil one when the test revealed that
Sabrina's sister Katrina is the evil
sibling Katrina was sent to live in the
Twin Cities in a place known as the
other realm while one Sabrina returns to
Greendale in chilling adventures the
other goes to hell where Lilith prepares
her for a full-time role as queen of
hell
Sabrina's style including her coronation
dress and white makeup revoke the look
of English Tudor monarch Elizabeth the
first who is known as a virgin queen and
whose reign included the attempted
invasion of England by the Spanish
Armada on top of that Sabrina's
coronation seems to pay specific homage
to the final scene of the
late 90s movie Elizabeth with each
Queens people buying down to her and
touching her dress and the Queen
signaling her ascent to the throne with
a little hand gesture the parallels
between Queen Elizabeth the first and
queen Submariner of hell become even
more striking when lilith speaks to
sabrina about what's in store for the
new young queen every queen must be made
battle-ready every girl must prepare for
war let nothing touch you but no man
hold power over you and emphasizing that
at least hellbound sabrina will be
uninterested in love sabrina tells
Lucifer I am ready
father to be married to help much as
Elizabeth the first was considered as
being went to her kingdom in part 3
Ambrose plays a key part in events when
he imprudent Strack down for the
Blackwood who's gone into hiding in Loch
Ness Scotland when they arrive Ambrose
explains that he already has some
knowledge of the location rockness know
that of a powerful rift Aleister Crowley
himself once harness his energies for
his own higher magics Ambrose's
familiarity with Crowley's life stems
from a time when Crowley act as a kind
of mentor to Ambrose my boy how did you
ever end up as part of a plot to rob the
Vatican young Crowley he was brilliant
charismatic and devoted to the Dark Lord
in real life Aleister Crowley was an
English occultist who gained notoriety
for many things including establishing
the religion of Thelema
aspects of which have inspired Wicca and
Satanism and like in the show Crowley
did actually live in Loch Ness for a
period of his life the show's nine
circles of hell are inspired by Dante's
Inferno the drawing of which appears in
the background on a school blackboard in
the first episode another clue that by
the end of part 3 Sabrina will travel
all the way to the ninth circle of hell
in Dante's epic poem the ninth circle is
reserved for people who've committed
treachery including Judas Iscariot so
it's fitting that that's were Caliban
trick Sabrina and betrays her trust on
top of that the ninth circle is also
were Sabrina breaks a promise she made
to future Sabrina to complete the time
loop by taking her place in the stone
prison
by the way the fact that chilling
adventures in cases its traitors in
stone is another hat tip to Dante's
Inferno where most of those condemned to
hell's ninth circle are trapped in ice
also in miss Wald wells classroom is
another blackboard where you can spot a
mention of Paradise Lost an epic poem by
John Milton it was in Paradise Lost that
Milton coined the term pandemonium for
the capital of hell not only is
pandemonium a crucial location in part
three
but Caliban himself has also sculpted
from the city's clay the facts story for
Herod's crown also notably connects to
the history of one of Riverdale's most
significant families the blossoms in
part three Ambrose discovers that this
first item of the unholy regalia was
passed between numerous people the last
known one being Private Benjamin blossom
who recovered the crown from Hitler's
bunker in 1945 interestingly Ambrose
goes on to explain that when Benjamin
blossom brought Herod's crown back to
Riverdale he was murdered by a group of
a cultists he wanted possession of the
magical unholy relic when Sabrina and
Ambrose visit Riverdale to locate the
crown they discover it's hidden in a
maple syrup tree which is especially
fitting because maple syrup has been
part of the blossom family business in
fact the connection between the blossoms
and King Herod seems particularly
appropriate as history and myth remember
Herod for having executed numerous male
children including several of his own
sons and of course season one spoilers
for Riverdale that show kicks off with
the murder of Jason blossom who it's
later revealed was killed by his own
father who is using a family syrup
business as a front for selling drugs
it's interesting that actor Jonathan
white-cell who plays robbing the
Hobgoblin in Sabrina also played the
part of Kurtz on Riverdale Kurtz was a
member of The Gargoyle gang but how can
the same actor play two different
characters and two shows that are
supposedly connected but perhaps it
could be another example of the
recurring theme of twins in both shows
enchanting Adventures of the black with
twins principal Hawthorne's twin who was
absorbed in the womb the image of Hilda
and Zelda as conjoined twins and now
after much hinting in previous seasons
sabrina has a double too or perhaps it's
all part of the shape-shifting ability
of puck or Robin Goodfellow characters
in English folklore when Sabrina
approaches Jimmy Platts ice cream truck
you can see it reads a chilling
adventure this isn't just a play on the
title of the show though it's also a
hint of the chilly fate that awaits a
Brunel a
in the episode when she ends up trapped
in the evil ice cream sellers freezer
curiously the same actor who plays Jimmy
Platt who's also going to appear on an
episode of Riverdale as a quiz show host
this again raises a question of how the
same actor can play different characters
in a shirred universe
previously in an interview with
Entertainment Tonight joining Adventures
in Riverdale showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa explained how been a
character who's already dead in
Riverdale later showed up as a pizza
delivery guy in Greendale
according to aguirre-sacasa Benz cameo
suggests a very deep mythology were time
and space Bend and even though Ben was
dead in Riverdale in Greendale everyone
pops up the dead don't stay dead longer
there's an amusing reference to the
crazy events that go on in Greendale's
neighboring town when we see the welcome
to Riverdale sign on the back you can
spot some Jughead Rafi T which dubs the
town murder capital of the world and in
the Riverdale spin-off show Katie Keene
Josie also refers to a hometown in the
same way I am from Riverdale it is the
murder capital of the world
after Hilda turns into spider Hilda she
asked dr. C to get her a hamburger in a
milkshake from a diner in Riverdale
undoubtedly referencing everyone's
favorite meeting place in Riverdale pops
chocolate shop spider Hilda also ends up
eating a Riverdale South size serpent
gang member who wanders into dr. C's
bookstore looking for something to eat
another Riverdale actor who makes an
appearance on chilling adventures is
nathalie bolt aka Penelope blossom
spoilers for Riverdale the nefarious
mastermind behind the black hood and the
gargoyle King in chilling adventures she
pops up in New Orleans however it turns
out it's not the real Penelope blossom
but rather prudence who's using
Penelope's form for a glamour trick
while she and Ambrose are on the hunt
for Blackwood the title of the final
episode Sabrina is legend is an
intriguing reference to the 2007 movie I
am Legend based on the book of the same
name the movie is known for its altern
ending in which spoilers for the film
Will Smith gets a happier ending than
the original one shown in cinemas
likewise in chilling adventures Sabrina
creates an alternate and happier time
line for herself when she decides not to
complete the time loop as future Sabrina
advised
and if you want to know much more about
the consequences Sabrina and will face
and part four as a result of altering
the timeline watch my ending explained
video you can tap the link here or click
the link in the video description so did
you spot any other cool details or
references in part 3 and what were your
favorite moments this season leave your
thoughts in the comments below if you
enjoyed this and a like and a share are
hugely appreciated tapleft my next
Sabrina video or tap write for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
[Music]